nous allons ouvrir une page politique à
présent dont le 7 8 avant de se pencher
sur la programmation on s'en doute vous
l'attendez de la fête de la musique la
direction à strasbourg et le parlement
européen pour une rencontre avec
constance le grip yvelinoise elle siège
en tant qu'eurodéputé de la
circonscription ile de france au sein du
groupe ppe elle est membre de l'ump
nous sommes donc à strasbourg devant le
parlement européen à l'invitation de
constance le gris est le siège pour le
groupe du ppe le parti populaire
européen elle est membre de l'ump nous
irons tout à l'heure à sa rencontre pour
le moment je vous propose une petite
visite guidée des lieux
oh
en fin de séance pour les quelques 7 154
députés des députés élus au suffrage
universel direct tous les cinq ans par
plus de 375 millions de personnes dans
27 états le second plus grand électorat
du monde derrière celui de l'inde
c'est l'une des plus importantes
institutions de l'europe elle détient le
pouvoir législatif et intervient dans
les domaines de l'agriculture des
régions ou encore du budget ici au
parlement européen se tienne des séances
plénières ou encore des commissions
groupe majoritaire le ppe parti
populaire européen composé notamment
pour l'allemagne de la cedeao l union
chrétienne démocrate ont encore du parti
populaire espagnol ainsi que pour la
france de l'ump et nous allons échanger
à présent avec constance le grip bonjour
merci de nous accueillir ici au
parlement puisque c'est de votre
initiative que vous nous recevez donc
ici aujourd'hui pour débuter j'aimerais
parler des prochaines échéances
européennes
c'est vraiment parle finalement assez
peu mais c'est en mai 2014
ça va juste suivre ces élections
municipales le scrutin va être un petit
peu noyé pour autant c'est important
récemment en france il ya un sondage
ps/ump front national qui sont qui
serait en tout cas au coude à coude au
prochain scrutin vous l'analysez comment
et quels sont vos inquiétudes autour de
ça est ce que c'est un échec aussi de
l'europe et de vos missions aussi de
députés européens que de sensibiliser la
population
alors ce sondage est une donnée
intéressante
il ya fort à parier que la situation
politique va encore considérablement
évoluer dans les mois à venir c'est vrai
que le scrutin européen prochain et le
25 mai 2014
simplement je prends ce sondage pour un
indications à un moment donnée
intéressante donc il y a un vrai défi
c'est vrai pour lutter contre
l'abstentionnisme pour faire partager à
l'un des fuites ou même l'opinion
il ya plutôt une mosquée de défiance de
l'opinion de l'opinion envers l'europe
il ya des inquiétudes qui sont sans
doute aussi légitime de par l'emploi
souvent dont on dira c'est de la faute
de l'europe aussi ça aussi en tant que
députée européenne qu'est ce que vous
pouvez répondre aux futurs électeurs sur
cette question là est ce que c'est la
faute de l'europe si les choses vont
aussi même quelquefois ce n'est pas la
faute de l'europe tout n'est pas de la
faute à bruxelles
il ya une stratégie du bouc émissaire
qui c'est vrai c'est la faute à
bruxelles a été trop abondamment utilisé
dans notre pays comme le rassurons nous
dans beaucoup d'autres pays européens
également la stratégie de bouc-émissaire
utilisé à mauvais escient par bien des
hommes politiques de droite comme de
gauche en france
mais il faut certainement travailler à
transformer les acquis déjà réalisé en
quelque chose plus durable de plus
consolidée et qui surtout commence à
faire apparaître à nos concitoyens que
sans l'europe
un certain nombre des crises récentes
qui l'ont connu et qu'il continue à
connaître et qui ne sont pas nés en
europe 1 je rappelle que le fait
déclencheur de la crise financière qui
s'est ensuite transformée en crise
économique puis en crise sociale c'est
le continent nord américain et c'est un
ensemble de politiques sur le continent
noir d'un mec que sans l'europe nous
aurions été certainement nous on n'était
pas encore plus violemment est
brutalement frappée et vous savez
l'aborder sans doute dans les prochains
mois en parler à ses différents
électeurs est ce que vous serez
candidate vous-même aux prochaines
élections est-ce que c'est déjà ça n'est
pas décidé mon parti c'est l'ump je suis
bien évidemment candidate à la
candidature auprès de ma famille
politique mais à l'heure actuelle
l'ump n'a pas encore fait son choix
alors il se dit aussi que c'est
difficile du côté de l'ump dit pas mais
justement c'est difficile du côté de
l'ump parce que entre les tensions qui
sont apparues entre les camps fillon les
camps copé les tensions autour des
primaires aux municipales aussi on se
dit qu'on pourrait retrouver sur les
listes européennes
des gens à caser parce qu'ils n'ont pas
d'autre mandat aussi c'est des choses
qui sortent dans la presse est ce que ça
les autres sujets celui effectivement de
la tendance française à aimer recaser
entre guillemets sur les européennes
les blessés du suffrage universel
c'est quelque chose que je trouve
dommageable non pas qu'il ne faille pas
reconnaître le travail souvent valeureux
qui a été fait par certaines de nos
personnalités et certains de nos anciens
ministres certains de nos anciens
députés mais je pense que le travail qui
lie à faire ici au parlement européen à
strasbourg et à bruxelles est
considérable que l'enjeu c'est non
seulement de rendre l'europe plus
efficace plus performante plus
protectrice mais c'est aussi de
travailler à renforcer la présence et
l'influencé française nous avons des
visions des idées une influence à
défendre un poids et une responsabilité
historique assumer en tant que france
pays fondateur de l'union européenne et
que pour cela il faut envoyer au
parlement européen des hommes et des
femmes dédié tant qu'à faire a tempéré
vous êtes députés eurodéputés
représentant la circonscription
d'ile-de-france et quel lien pour un
député européen avec sa circonscription
d'origine avec l'ile-de-france les
yvelines aussi vous êtes natif des
yvelines d'affaires alors les yvelines
mon département la cale effectivement où
je retourne régulièrement quoique je n'y
habite plus j'habite dans les
hauts-de-seine et mon bureau franciliens
si je peux dire est installé à paris en
plein coeur de la capitale
le retour il est hebdomadaire à chaque
fin de semaine et les choses démarrent
souvent dès le jeudi après midi
je quitte bruxelles ou strasbourg où
nous emmener les plénières les réunions
de commission les réunions de groupe
pour aller à la rencontre de mes
concitoyennes de mes concitoyens
défense ile de france pour les électeurs
pour les faire voter nous essayons de
porter en liaison avec les élus
parlementaires aux régionaux locaux
d'île de france en liaison avec
l'antenne bruxelloise et européennes la
région
ile de france en lien avec les
responsables politiques de ma famille
politique nous étions de porter ensemble
de dossiers et de sujets et de message
proprement franciliens défendre un
certain nombre de thématiques
francilienne une grande région riche
entre guillemets si on la compare à
d'autres régions européennes
incontestablement un fort niveau de
développement économique et mais
néanmoins des problèmes
une forte urbanisation mais aussi
quelques territoires ruraux une partie
des partants des évident d'ailleurs est
encore marquée par la ruralité et par
des thématiques rural nous avons
évidemment à coeur nous les visions
eurodéputé issu de ce territoire de
défendre également les intérêts de notre
région et nous allons régulièrement
autant que faire se peut en répondant
des invitations en rencontrant à son
acteurs locaux régionaux en allant sur
le terrain à la rencontre de nos
compatriotes franciliens vous siégez
depuis 2010 vous avez fait ce mandat
quelques mois après les élections
puisque vous êtes remonté d'une case
après le départ de michel barnier
voilà sur la liste de l'ump en france
pour ce groupe ppe quel bilan vous
faites de votre mandat tout simplement
écouter c'est un bilan que j'ai plaisir
à qualifiée de globalement positif non
pas pour me lancer
déco des fleurs mais simplement parce
que j'en ai tiré à titre personnel je
dois le dire beaucoup de bénéfices sur
le plan intellectuel et sans plan
politique il est absolument passionnant
surtout après de nombreuses années
passées dans la politique nationale dans
la politique française pour pouvoir
ouvrir grand les fenêtres je dirais sûr
le reste de l'europe et sur les enjeux
les préoccupations les cultures les
aspirations d'autres peuples européens
c'est bien sûr un enrichissement et
personnelle et politique qu'il y avait
une action justement une action à
retenir de l'ensemble du bilan qui a été
menée et qui a pu aboutir
j'en retiendrai peut-être deux d'abord
une sur un sujet qui me tient à coeur et
sur lequel j'ai personnellement beaucoup
travaillé sur lequel je me suis beaucoup
investi en tant que rapporteur pour mon
groupe politique et qui est sur le point
d'aboutir c'est la sphère de quelques
semaines s'est facilité améliorer les
procédures de reconnaissance des titres
et les qualifications professionnelles
enjeux de la mobilité professionnelle
est un enjeu important
travailler à construire un véritable
marché européen du travail faciliter les
mouvements des professionnels à l'inter
de l'europe répondre aux besoins qui se
font jour de paye et de professionnels
hautement qualifiés qui existent souvent
en quantité et en qualité dans d'autres
pays mais qui ont peine à trouver chez
eux de l'emploi organisé ce marché
européen du travail répondre à
l'aspiration de nos concitoyens pour de
la mobilité pour la possibilité
d'épanouir générer leurs trajectoires
professionnelles dans un grand espace
européen
il ya eu là un gros travail qui a été
fait pour améliorer facilité rendre plus
efficace et plus rapide surtout les
procédures de reconnaissance des titres
et des qualifications professionnelles
avec l'instauration d'un instrument
qu'on appelle la carte professionnelle
européenne un sésame volontaires pour
ceux et celles qui veulent un sésame
pour aller plus facilement travailler
dans un autre état que son état
d'origine certains dossiers qui m'a
beaucoup tenaient à coeur et sur lequel
je me suis beaucoup investi et que nous
avons mené à bon port
de manière générale je crois que dans
cette mandature 6 et le groupe ppe
auquel j'appartiens s'est énormément
impliqué a été vraiment je crois aux
avant gardes
nous avons essayé de répondre aux
inquiétudes de nos concitoyens après
l'éclatement
de la bulle financière après les
catastrophes que la sphère financière
avait occasionné nous avons essayé
d'introduire de l'ordre de la régulation
est un peu plus je dirais de contrôle
dans la sphère financière les banques
les compagnies d'assurances les fonds
d'investissement nous avons lutté contre
certaines dérives
et certaines pratiques financières
totalement folle totalement délirante en
interdisant ou encadrer très strictement
certains produits financiers pernicieux
toxiques
abracadabrantesque qui avait causé
beaucoup de mal à l'économie réelle nous
avons essayé de remettre de l'ordre de
remettre en quelque sorte la finance qui
était ni régulés débridé au service de
l'économie réelle et on verra comment
les concitoyens réagissent aux
prochaines élections s'ils seront
analysés où nous les les bénéfices de
l'europe ainsi encore une fois pour nous
avoir invités ici donc au parlement à
strasbourg
ainsi s'achève cette visite du parlement
européen le prochain scrutin se
déroulera le 25 mai 2014
actuellement 12 euros un député en
ile-de-france d'harlem désir pour le
parti socialiste à eva joly pour europe
ecologie les verts en passant par
marielle de sarnez également pour le
modem vous en voyez d'ailleurs
actuellement la liste complète sur votre
écran les images de ce rendez vous
depuis le parlement européen à
strasbourg était signée patrick jacques
de dixmude